one guy
had um murdered his mum and his sister
in a psychotic State and had been found
um running in a beach in the Northwest
with no clothes on with something
inserted inside him and
um this is after his mum pleading for
psychiatric help and this is after him
also pleading for psychiatric help and
having been turned away from hospital
[Music]
how did you decide on the first place to
become a prison officer
I left University in 1998 having studied
applied psychology with the plan to be a
psychologist however
the prison service paid slightly more so
I thought I'll join the prison Service
as a prison officer with the plan to
ultimately move over to the psychology
department which never happened and I
ended up staying as a prison officer I
started working at a place called style
prison and it's a female prison based in
the north of England in just outside of
Manchester I'd never had a fight in my
life I was this middle class sort of
well to do
um chipper you know young enthusiastic
thing that was thrown into a female
prison full of drug addicts murderers
sex offenders
young offenders juvenile prisoners it
was the full mix and nothing quite
prepares you for working with female
prisoners they are the most complex
um type of type of offender that I've
ever worked with nearly 90 of them have
experienced some sort of sexual
um physical emotional abuse in their
lifetime and obviously that translates
into their behavior that translates into
their drug use
um and that stuff that we had to deal
with on a daily basis and you know the
the sad thing is that we are all one bad
decision or one mistake away from being
in prison you know many many people have
relatives or friends that have been in
prison and you know
to just assume that every one of them is
a scumbag is just not right you know
some people make mistakes
what would you say were the most
upsetting things you've seen in the
so quite often women will ligature try
and hang themselves
and I walked into a cell one day and a
woman
had suspended herself from the light
fitting in the cell
and at the same time she had cut her
face with a razor blade and she'd also
cut her neck and I remember the smell
and it's only if you've experienced lots
of blood that you really know what the
smell of blood is and it is it is that
iron metallic smell and we didn't know
where to start we didn't know where to
start helping this girl we didn't know
whether she was bleeding to death we
didn't know whether we were going to be
able to resuscitate her from the
ligature because it had been so serious
it was it was just and we're just prison
officers at this point we're not meant
you know we're not mental health nurses
we're not general nurses we are just
trying to save that person's life
um
fortunately she was saved and even
though the ligature attempt was serious
I'd say enough to to sort of
um
make her lose like temporary
Consciousness we were able to bring her
back
but it's things like that but that's
just one of many many incidents that
that I can recall
um that were almost on a daily basis at
some points
have you ever been scared at work
[Music]
I've been scared a few times yeah there
was an occasion where I was left alone
with a male prisoner
um who was a rapist
and I didn't have any method of
contacting other staff and I was taken
from one area of the prison to the other
and he started touching me
he had started touching me I'd managed
to get away I was I was I was upset but
but I was okay it was only later on when
I found out what he was in for and the
fact he wasn't left should be you know
should have been left alone with female
staff that it really hit me almost like
a PTSD thing so you know it was that
Terror of what could have happened if I
hadn't got away because he was a big
Hulk of a man and I'm five foot two and
you know I was this 21 year old you know
little thing that you know with not a
lot of life experience
would you say that prison officer is
like a more male dominated job generally
so
yeah so the prison service has very very
typically
and I'll talk about the male estate is
is very
much being dominated by men
um I would go as far to say it was an
incredibly misogynistic environment
because people always say did you have
problems with the male prisoners and I
was like apart from that one instant
nine times out of ten they were dead
respectful staff didn't give a [ __ ] try
and force themselves on you all sorts
it's horrendous
from being a prison officer how did you
progress to become a prison governor and
what prison did that happen in
so whilst I was at style prism as a
prison officer
I had a bad experience in which I was
assaulted quite badly by a female
prisoner
and I remember being really really
disappointed in the actions of my
manager on that day and him not
coming to my rescue effectively
basically hiding behind a gate
and I got really frustrated and I got
really angry and when I came back to
work after I'd been off off sick I
thought I can do that job better than
him
and I also wanted to change things it
sat it really sounds sort of like Airy
fairy but you know you've changed the
system from within I went to Liverpool
prison when I was 27 in 2005 as a female
principal officer the only principal
officer so that's the highest uniform
rank so it goes prison officer senior
officer principal officer
quite quickly again I got after a couple
years or so
I got bored and thought I knew it all
and I thought right I'll go for my
Governor's exams now I worked at
Manchester prison which is a category a
high security prison worked very closely
with
um Ashworth Hospital which is a high
secure psychiatric hospital so you were
dealing with you know some very very
dangerous people
um not only in terms of the behavior but
in terms of their offenses outside so um
one guy
had um murdered his mum and his sister
in a psychotic State and had been found
um running in a beach in the Northwest
with no clothes on with something
inserted inside him he was only young I
think he was about he might have been
about 20 21 and he had it was later
found out that he had also raped his
sister's dead body
and this is after his mum pleading for
psychiatric help and this is after him
also pleading for psychiatric help and
having been turned away from hospital
and in hindsight you would think as a
inverted commas normal person like that
person should go instantly to a
psychiatric hospital however they didn't
because quite often what you will find
is when a prisoner is on remand before
they've gone to trial there is a period
of time where they are assessed to see
if they're faking it which some of them
do or whether they're actually genuine
if they can be medicated therefore you
know found culpable
um so there's there's lots of processes
and procedures that need to go into
place and he um came to Manchester
Healthcare
like a scared rabbit and you would never
in a million years believe that this
boy had murdered his mother and his
sister and and it was he was he was
caught bang to rights he he had admitted
it
um
and he was he was really difficult he
was he was still very very clearly
psychotic and when you're dealing with
someone who is just so thought
disordered and it you know in deep into
their psychosis you you know it's really
difficult to relate to them or engage
with them communicate with them on any
sort of meaningful level
I think one member of Staff managed to
establish and I think it was his
obsession with um
I think it might have been Harry Potter
and a member of staff was able to sort
of get through to him to talk about the
books or to you know there was sort of a
little bit of commonality there and we
were able to use that to sort of because
we couldn't medicate him we had to rely
on sort of our relationships
but unfortunately he went on to commit
some really serious acts of self-harm he
poured boiling water all over himself he
cut himself he and eventually he went to
um Ashworth Hospital which is which is
where he should have been but you know
it's tragic because you can see these
people the the general public just
assume these people are evil but I've
seen real mental illness that it's so
disturbing and it you know you feel
powerless
because you can't treat them we cannot
treat we cannot pin them down and
forcibly medicate them like you can in a
hospital
with all these things you talk about I
wonder how do you deal with the
emotional pressure of that
like in your personal life
I can look back now and see that I had
some really sort of bad coping
strategies
um
there was a big culture of drinking at
the time when I first started as a
prison officer so a lot of us would
socially drink I mean they provide us
with mental health training in a limited
capacity to help us deal with prisoners
but there's very little
that's done to sort of help us deal with
ourselves but I'll give you sort of one
specific example there was a prisoner
called Mark Bridger again a high profile
prisoner and the um
around
2013
2014 and he was bought into US accused
of the murder of April Jones in a Welsh
village called mcconkliff
and he was the Prime Suspect
he came into prison with a predetermined
story that he had got behind the wheel
of his 4x4 drunk
and that he'd knocked April off her bike
killed her
or couldn't at least did not to
unconscious
put her in his vehicle and then went and
disposed of the body but he was so drunk
he couldn't remember where he disposed
the body he couldn't remember if he'd
put it in water he couldn't remember if
he'd burnt it but he was basically
admitting to some of it but this was his
story so I had this day off to go
um Christmas shopping with my mum
and I remember being in the queue and my
phone going and I answered my phone and
one of the my my team said
they found bones in his fireplace and
even now when I think about it my
stomach just like churns a little bit
so I'm with my mum and she saw my face
drop
so we knew everything that he told us
was a complete and utter lie
there was other evidence coming through
there was blood splatter evidence there
was child pornography evidence there was
there was all sorts
and they found little palm prints on the
inside of the window
so he'd obviously taken her while she
was alive and she'd obviously pressed
her hands against the window to try and
get out
and my little boy was a similar age at
the time but I was off that day and I
didn't have my team around me and it sat
with me
and I couldn't tell anyone I couldn't
tell my husband at the time I couldn't
speak to anyone and it made me feel
physically sick and when I went into
work the next day or the day after to
face him
I wanted to rip his face off
because everything he was still sticking
to this story
and I'm just like you're a liar you're a
liar you're a psychopath but I can't say
that because I've got to be professional
this was at the conclusion of the trial
and I think the stress of the last nine
months and you know being party to this
information and having to deal with this
man on a daily basis and maintain
professionalism and maintain a sort of
caring attitude just finally got to us
and you know there was a few of us in
the office and we just broke down and
sobbed and sobbed and sobbed
why did you decide to quit this job
so I had done 21 years in the prison
service I um have a diagnosed mental
health issue myself that has been
prevalent since childhood
um for which I'm medicated and I've
always functioned really really well
um
the work was fantastic for me because it
gave me a purpose gave me structure gave
me you know an opportunity to help
people
um that really sort of gave me some
value and and worth and and
um really fired me on because I thought
I was actually doing some good what I
was probably neglecting was my own
self-care and my own self-worth and my
my sort of own mental health in 2019 I
stopped taking my medication and
um I became quite ill quite quickly
and I went to my manager and I had a bit
of a cry and I said I feel overwhelmed I
feel stress I've got this diagnosis and
he was shocked
and
about two weeks later I tried to take my
own life and from that point I didn't go
back to the prison service because that
was my point of finally getting into
recovery
so how are you feeling now what are you
doing now
so because I'm medically retired
um I'm very limited as to what I can do
so one of the things that I realized
finishing work is that self-care
is like a full-time job so that's how I
I see it and my my job is to now is to
be the best mum it's to be a good
partner
it's to manage my mental health on a
daily basis
and yeah and I'm happy to talk about my
mental health because I again I think
that you know
the prison service being very male
dominated is like don't show your
feelings don't show your emotions
nothing you know don't cry you know you
wear your your Teflon suits and your
invincibility cloak and nothing can get
to you and actually I'm thinking I was
pretty high functioning and if this can
happen to me you know how many other the
people can be affected and unfortunately
we have had members of Staff take their
own lives I know personally two members
of staff that took their own lives in
very tragic
tragic circumstances
um so I consider myself the lucky one to
sort of
recognized uh that wasn't well and and
to have got the help that I needed
do you think that prison guards and
people just gender people working in
prisons do you think they should get
more mental health supports do you think
more should be done for them more
training
yeah I I mean the the the support for
staff is is woefully lacking and I mean
absolutely woefully lacking but in terms
of day-to-day stuff you just relying on
your colleague what what the prison
service really needs to realize is you
know if you invest in your staff if your
staff feel valued if your staff feel
cared for that will translate downwards
you know how can we sort of
ask prisoners to behave in a pro-social
way to to sort of go out and and form
positive relationships and interact well
with their families when we're not doing
this doing the same it's just craziness
uh but unfortunately everything comes
down to money money and time
I think had I still been in the prison
service now there's no way I would have
accessed treatment there's no way I
would have been sort of where I am now
I still struggle but I I will never work
as a prison Governor again
but that's not necessarily A Bad Thing
[Music]
day 10.
um naked
uh trying to pull his own
testicles off
inserting things up his back passage
refusing any medication
um covering excrement